[Musica]
[Applauso]
sono emozionatissimo
devo dire la verità quando mi hanno
detto che sarei venuto qui a terni di
rovigo sarei
veramente avuto un fremito non sono
abituato a parlare così liberamente
senza mascherarmi dietro a delle battute
infatti prima dietro ai camerini avevo
avanti indietro preoccupato pensando mi
ricorderò tutto ce la farò non ce la
farò e come spesso mi accade prima di
entrare in ceramica gli un'ansia allora
in questi casi mi concentro e penso alle
parole che mi disse anna laura messeri
la mia insegnante di recitazione al
teatro stabile di genova che vedendomi
agitato e dietro le quinte il giorno del
mio primo debutto vero teatrale mi disse
enzo ricordati il dilettante si
preoccupa il professionista se ne occupa
concentrati su quello che devi fare se è
teso fi esercizio di rilassamento
hai paura di cespi carthy su qualche
battuta fi esercizio di articolazione in
poche parole concentrati occupati di
quello che andrai a fare
e anche prima l'ho fatto e come sempre
accade ogni volta che lo faccio ecco che
la preoccupazione come per magia
sparisci
ma che cos'è la preoccupazione la
treccani la definisce così
preoccupazione pensiero che occupa la
mente determinando lo stato di
inquietudine di apprensione ansia
incertezza timore e simili
ma pensiero che occupa la mente è un po
come se dentro la nostra testa ci fosse
un vuoto da colmare
e se non lo riempiamo con delle azioni
utili
ecco che si riempirà di pensieri
negativi
fantastico quando ci penso dico
veramente allora basta pensare delle
cose utili un po come quando sei a casa
da solo magari e hai paura vi capita mai
magari sei lì nel letto da solo e c'è
silenzio silenzio che non esiste il
silenzio per noi esseri umani una
convenzione per noi il silenzio e quando
noi sentiamo il rumore delle lancette
un rumore un mobile che cigolano
e tu sei nel letto da solo e hai paura
perché la sera prima hai visto
l'esorcista
e ti preoccupi pensi che casa tua sei
indemoniata pensi oggi ora il diavolo mi
prendevi porta via
e tutto questo va avanti finché non di
cini di occuparti del problema e ti
attivi ti alzi dal letto vai alla porta
[Musica]
che c'è
vengo lì e
ti giri
meno male è un ladro
il dilettanti si preoccupa il
professionista se ne occupa il
dilettante riempie la testa di odio che
ne sarà di me
il professionista invece la occupa con
frasi tipo che cosa devo fare per
risolvere il problema
ecco la grande differenza
ora per anni ho pensato che questo ho
detto questo
questo pensiero fosse solo utile per gli
attori per metterci nelle condizioni
migliori per recitare per sconfiggere
quella ansietà da palcoscenico da
prestazione che se non ben controllata
può diventare veramente paralizzante poi
invece pensando ci ho capito che questo
detto questo consiglio può essere utile
in tutti gli ambiti della vita in tutte
le nostre attività
quante volte
abbiamo rinunciato a qualcosa che ci
piaceva solo per la preoccupazione di
sbagliare o di fallire
quante volte abbiamo rinunciato a un
sogno solo perché invece di occuparsi
attivamente per realizzarlo e
trasformarli in un progetto ci siamo
fatti sconfiggere da pensieri tipo non
sono abbastanza bravo non ce la farò non
me lo merito
quante volte
e allora ecco che
ho riflettuto sulla mia vita
e in effetti è vero io ogni volta che
non ho centrato un obiettivo
e perché non me ne sono occupato
veramente fino in fondo a scuola non era
un luminare non ero bravo mi lamentavo
anche ma non sono abbastanza bravo ma
perché perché non me ne occupavo fino in
fondo perché fondamentalmente a me non
me ne fregava niente di essere il primo
della classe al pomeriggio stavo in casa
a guardare la televisione la mia
passione era già la comicità passava le
giornate a guardare a imitare a studiare
i comici e infatti faccio l'attore non
faccia l'ingegnere è normale
occuparsi ragionavo da dilettante a
scuola
ora è chiaro non è che per realizzare un
sogno sia sufficiente occuparsene non è
non basta purtroppo questo non basta ci
sono delle cose che sfuggono alla nostra
volontà perché poi non è importante solo
occuparsene importante anche il come te
ne occupi il perché te ne occupi e da
ragazzino ad esempio era un ragazzino mi
vedete sono grassottello sono sempre
stato così un po più basso un panettone
ed ero la vittima prediletta dei
bulletti semi schernivano mi prendevano
in giro piangevo tornava a casa anche mi
ricordo che la mattina quando mi vestivo
per andare a scuola piangevo perché
sapevo che mi avrebbero fatto passare
delle ore infernali e invece mio padre
che era un uomo sicuro di sé nato nel
1939 a ridosso della guerra venuto
supera le macerie
ecco mio padre invece era era era duro
era sicuro di sé
di fronte a questo figlio timido
impacciato cercava di motivarmi a suo
modo a enzo tutti devi svegliare tu devi
imparare a difenderti
se qual è il tuo problema enzo tu sei
troppo buono io questa cosa che non hai
capito cosa vuol dire essere troppo
buono è come se ci fosse un limite di
bontà superato il quale te lo prendi
quel posto
a intenderci non ero io essere troppo
buono erano tutti gli altri al limite
essere un po tutti stronzi abbiate
pazienza e invece enzo ti devi sbagliare
così per svegliarmi mio padre siccome io
non mi occupavo del problema lui da
bravo padre se n'è occupato al posto mia
e cos'ha fatto
mi ha portato in una palestra di
pugilato
da ragazzina avevo 12 13 anni sono
entrati questa palestra con mio padre
i pugili lo senti valore se di questo
odore questo è l'odore della rabbia
della ribellione del sacrificio a papà
pensavo autori di ascelle cioè l'odore
non si respira i pazienti
certo punto l'allenatore ci nota si
avvicina
vede me e mio padre roberto piras su un
campione olimpionico il sardo più alto
d'italia ho mai visto un sardo così alto
vede me e mio padre avete bisogno sì
volevo farle provare qui il pugilato da
mio figlio mattia winnie the pooh
perché il basso e mi fecero provare sono
stato a far fu girato per due anni sono
arrivato anche a fare qualche piccolo
allenamento in palestra sai in gergo si
dice i guanti ma non ero portato non me
ne fregava niente io facevo pugilato per
compiacere mio padre che dall'angolo
anche faceva il tifo mentre facevo i
piccoli incontri in palestra di
allenamento enzo ringhia papa ha
ricordati per fare botti ci vogliono
sempre due sacchi uno per prenderle e
uno per darle ora si vede che a me
secondo non me l'hanno mai dato
perché mi lega avevo preso tante di
quelle botte che sono arrivato al re ly
all'angolo da mio padre che papà rose di
questo odore si fa cos'è arrabbiano ma
lassù fatta addosso papa
scherzi a parte
di quell esperienza mi è rimasto solo un
ricordo il pulsare delle tempie
le orecchie calde e il cuore che batteva
forte la paura di farmi male
ecco il pugilato in questo non mente o
te ne occupi
scusate ho te ne occupi
oppure i rischi di farti male
e il ricordo che quando sono tornato a
casa con le labbra gonfie ho pensato da
questo momento in poi io me ne occupo
me ne occupo di non occuparmene mai più
buttato via tutto guantoni scarpe tutto
io volevo fare il comico
io ho sempre desiderato di fare l'attore
di stare sul palcoscenico non avevo il
coraggio di dirlo ai miei genitori mi
chiudevo in cameretta sognavo ma io ho
sempre voluto fare questo ma fin da
bambino alle elementari mi ricordo
l'insegnante chiedeva che cosa vuoi fare
da grande c'era che rispondeva
l'ingegnere chi medita io ho sempre
risposto
un bambino deficiente
[Applauso]
se mi volto indietro vedo un viaggio
lunghissimo oggi 50 anni vedo un viaggio
confuso pieno di false partenze di
indecisioni di ritardi sulla tabella di
marcia ma è il mio viaggio e lo rifarei
tutto dalla fin dall'inizio alla fine
chiaramente i viaggi nella vita non sono
tutti meravigliosi
ci sono dei viaggi che per loro natura
non sono destinati arrivare in porto
come quello del titanic no eccovelo dire
a loro che è più importante il viaggio
che non la metta a comprendere però
anche io ho vissuto il mio
personalissimo titanic perché nella vita
ci sono cose che noi possiamo
controllare altre sulle quali non
abbiamo nessun tipo di controllo ma che
possiamo influenzare come ben sappiamo e
altri ancora che proprio non dipendono
da nessuno non abbiamo nessun tipo di
controllo e quello che ora vi vado a
raccontare appartiene all'ultima
categoria
quello dove proprio non hai controllo vi
spiego otto anni fa con mia moglie
sposati da poco
decidiamo di avere un bimbo
pensiamo il mondo è pieno di imbecilli
sì ma un in più non guasterà
e allora figlio del dilettante si
preoccupa è il professionista se ne va
incomincia ad occuparmene insieme a mia
moglie devo dire la verità dopo un po
che non c'erano risultati sebbene
divertente dopo di cominciava a essere
frustrante un po come giocare a biliardo
hai voglia a mettere il gessetto dopo
puoi andare in buca e invece niente
siamo andati allora dal suo ginecologo
che gentile ci ha fatto delle domande ci
ha chiesto come lo fate quando lo fate
ogni quanto lo fate
ce lo mette il gessetto ce lo metto
gessetto
ci ha dato dei consigli pratici ecco da
quel momento
la procreazione non ha più a che fare
con l'amore è una scienza a che fare con
il calcolo preciso del giorno più
fertile per lei al calcolo preciso di
astinenza per lui per arrivare carico al
grande match
dopo un anno e mezzo di questa vita
senza risultato siamo tornati dal medico
ma bisogna vederci chiaro facciamolo
spermiogramma l'analisi di liquido
seminale una cosa delle più imbarazzanti
che abbia fatto nella mia vita
mele occupo
perché ormai bisognava occuparsene ea
farla breve consegno la mia provetti na
il medico sull'erta subito visionato con
il vetrino di un microscopio e ha
cominciato a dirmi agli
spermatozoi sono pochi
lenti
demotivati
dentro di me li o immaginati tipo
l'elettore medio alle amministrative se
quello che dice ma non andiamo a votare
che tanto non cambia
[Applauso]
e stato scherzi a parte uno dei momenti
più bui della mia vita come potete ben
immaginare
fortunatamente mia moglie invece di
preoccuparsi ha deciso di occuparsi di
me e io di occuparmi di lei
ed è questo che vorrei dire prima di
lasciarvi che forse la cosa più
importante
è occuparsi dell'amore bisogna diventare
dei professionisti si ma dell'amore e vi
vorrei lasciare con questa frase
meravigliosa piena di saggezza non mi ha
chiaramente
ora la troviamo perché come vedete io me
ne occupo ma sono incapaci faccio
partire cose
me l'hanno spiegato ha due tasti ha due
tasti li sbaglia pensate la capacità
ride
la saggezza
non consultarti con le tue paure
ma con le tue speranze e i tuoi sogni
non pensate alle vostre frustrazioni ma
al vostro potenziale irrealizzato non
preoccupatevi per ciò che avete provato
è fallito ma di ciò che vi ancora
possibile fare papa giovanni xxiii
grazie